it's the beginning of January 2018 so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which I talk about what we've
got going on in January and what went on
in December I always like to begin by
bringing up three big things that I
would like to call your attention to so
big thing number one right now you've
got the opportunity to vote on which
four author's I'm going to add to my
monthly series that I do here in the
Milwaukee area but which I put on
YouTube worlds of speculative fiction so
the link for that is below I'll talk
more about that in just a bit
the second big thing is connected with
that I've actually created a free online
class and the reason I owe Academy
worlds of speculative fiction if you
want not only access to the the videos
in an organized fashion but the handouts
and other things that I'm adding in
there that'll make for a much better
experience you want to enroll in that
that class and again it's free the third
big thing that I'm particularly happy
about as well is that since we've passed
the particular level of support what we
call a milestone in patreon last month I
started doing monthly AMA that has asked
me anything session so I'm going to
continue doing that through 2018 those
are the three big things now let's talk
about the year that passed in the year
ahead so what went on and what did we do
in December it was kind of a winding
down month as it usually is because
they're either the holidays my kids come
to visit there's Christmas concerts to
go to all sorts of other things parties
and in addition to that of course I had
the usual things of an academic semester
because I was teaching three classes
this last semester almost a full-time
load actually a full-time load in many
universities in addition to doing
everything else so those classes were
coming to a close I didn't do quite as
many talks as
in in recent months although that's
setting apart pretty high I did do an
online webinar and seminars on epictetus
choice and character and those went
quite well we finished up our year two
of the world of speculative fiction
monthly talk series by looking at
Octavia Butler xenogenesis or Lilith's
brood trilogy some really great
discussion you can see the video for
that down below I held the first AMA
that's asking me anything session at the
very end of the month once we crossed a
particular threshold for monthly monthly
pledges from patreon if you don't know
what patreon is it's it's a crowdfunding
site and it's used by creators like me
who you know generate online content
whether it be blog posts you know other
sorts of writing comics or videos and
podcasts so if you like the sort of work
that I'm doing and you want a way to
support even if it's just a dollar a
month go ahead and click the link below
or click the card above and you can
become a patreon supporter and there's a
lot of cool perks that come with that
anyway we passed up the level at which I
committed to doing a monthly AMA so we
did it that went on for about an hour
and a half and I answered a lot of
questions you can see the video for that
below we also did some other online
events from my patreon supporters I do a
philosophy chat which is exclusive to
them half hour Haegele we also do an
exclusive chat but I do a once a month I
do a public Q&A and discussion session
anybody's got questions on Hale can show
up and ask and of course we had her to
philosophy pop-ups one in YouTube live
one in Facebook live
focused this time on philosophy
festivals and holidays those were quite
fun what else you know like I mentioned
I finished up classes so that took quite
a bit of time because it was quite a
heavy load for somebody who's not a
traditional academic anymore to ethics
classes one world
using values class by the way if you're
interested in the world views and values
class look at the links below you can
take that same class - of course the the
paperwork of doing homework and getting
graded in the reason IO Academy so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
check it out
I did some podcast episode recordings
and actually also recorded an interview
with a national public radio station out
west they called me up and wanted to
talk about stoicism and some of the
podcast episodes actually aired this
this last month - with the pants I cast
conversations between the hosts me and
Mark Lindsay Meyer of the partially
examined life so that was that was
pretty cool links to those are below as
well spent a lot of time doing tutorials
you know it's the end of the years so
there's a lot of you know people doing
kneading stuff right right then but I
also have so you know quite a few
regular tutorial sessions with with
people anywhere from you know one to
three hours a week with them did some
academic coaching I did a good bit of
philosophical counseling and I did some
consulting work as well as far as videos
go it was not as productive a month as
as I usually like to hope for but I did
get quite a bit done I shot five
half-hour Haegele videos I got some core
concept videos done on Heidegger I'm
just finishing up now with his plato's
doctrine of truth I did also release a
previously recorded video of a
conversation with Daniel Robertson
Donald Robertson sorry you know of
modern stoicism and really one of the
founders of the organization so that was
that was great I managed to talk to him
a bit at snowicon' about that and I
recorded the AMA session I recorded the
pop-up session on YouTube and I record
the webinar so you can you can see all
of those below if you if you miss them
what do we have coming up in January so
I'm not gonna try to do what I have done
in previous years which is talk about
the whole year ahead I'll do a separate
video on that if people are interested
enough if you are just you know leave a
comment and and tell me that you are and
I'll get to that later on not
necessarily this week certainly this
month talking about like the big plan
for 2018 and all the different projects
that I'm I'm working on all right so
back to January itself what have we got
going on for events we have just a few
face-to-face events although if you're
here in the Milwaukee area should
mention that we I'm also at some other
things weekly I'm at the shut up and
write session down here at the Stone
Creek but here's the things that we've
got coming up so Wednesday the 10th at 5
o'clock we're doing our public half hour
Haegele Q&A and discussion session if
you want to know more about that go to
the half hour Haegele project you'll
always announce it on the blog anybody
who's got questions about Hegel German
idealism even you know things more
broadly and philosophy will answer those
questions we give priority to them
otherwise we often meander off and does
all sorts of discussions about biography
and current politics and things like
that on Thursday the 11th from 7:00 to
8:30 p.m. at the Brookfield Public
Library we are beginning the 3rd year of
our worlds of speculative fiction series
and we're gonna be talking about one of
my favorite authors a favorite of mine
since college you notice this book is
pretty well worn this is the second copy
of it that I had this is something that
I particularly love and we're gonna talk
about Bohr Hayes works more broadly but
a lot of the stories are going to be
coming directly out of that labyrinths
volume so if you're here in the
Milwaukee area that is going to be a
really great conversation if not you'll
be able to see the
video for it on Saturday the 13th at 2
o'clock p.m. Central Time patron is a
patreon exclusive event a philosophy had
to do this monthly philosophy chat for
some of my supporters in patreon and
certain months I open it up to all of my
patreon supporters so that's an
open-ended thing anybody can can bring
up whatever topics they want and see how
I you know address them we get into some
great conversations there Friday the
19th again Central Time one o'clock I'll
be holding the next ask me anything
session on YouTube live so if you're if
you're interested in that mark it on
your calendar you can actually go to the
link below and you will find a way that
you can set up a calendar reminder for
that if you if you really want to get on
that ask me anything session Thursday
the 25th another local event if you're
here in the Milwaukee area and you've
got an interest in stoicism we have from
6:00 to 7:00 p.m. at the Shorewood
Public Library the MKE stoic fellowship
and that'll up the the month for for my
events kind of taking it easy a bit but
February will probably be a bit busier
got a lot of work going on with stoicism
today and the stoic fellowship I have
assumed the the chair ship of a
committee in the stoic fellowship which
looks to be a good bit of work but also
you know it's it's a good service for me
to do I'm still editing stoicism today
and I've got some plans for what's
coming up that's a lot of you know other
work on that part and we're engaged in a
lot of discussions about coordinating
things like you know stoic on and stoic
on exes and all that sort of business
I'll be doing some blog posting this
month more than the last month of course
I didn't do it a lot last month so
that's setting the bar a little bit low
and I think you'll probably see some of
my podcast guest appearances coming out
later on this month and I
got plans to record additional ones with
other podcasters now one of the big
things that I wanted to talk about you
have the opportunity to vote on the type
form link below which of the ten OAuth
errs that I'm putting into the list
these are the ones who got the most
votes or the most interest from my
previous query about the worlds of
speculative fiction series we're gonna
you get to select four out of that ten
and the top four are the ones who I'm
going to discuss in the series in the
months that are still TBA so if you if
you want to have a stake in that you
know you want to get involved the other
thing that's really cool with the worlds
of speculative fiction I decided that I
would you know create a teachable reason
IO Academy class which you can sign up
for below I'm still building it out but
I'm happy to have people poking around
looking at the videos I have a lot of
other content to add and upload in the
coming weeks or so about these authors
but I've got all 22 of the sessions in
there in the free class that you can get
into I'm putting handouts from the
sessions
I'm putting additional resources you've
got reading selections all sorts of cool
stuff so if you're interested in that
series I'll I'll be adding to it by the
way too as we do each talk so when we do
the bore haste talk that videos going
right in the handouts that I'm
developing are going right in and
everyone will be able to participate in
some way and we might we might spend
some other stuff off from that I don't
know well we'll see what happens if
there's sufficient interest what else
I'm building additional courses and the
reason I owe academy I haven't had the
chance to get to them but I'm now
marking out time to do that teaching the
three classes in academic institutions
took a lot of time now that I'm not
doing that this semester well actually
until later on so I'm still teaching for
marys and in March I can start I can
finish up that Aristotle categories
class I
to have that out this month the Cicero
stoic paradoxes I don't think that I
will have the Marcus Aurelius
meditations class done by the end of
this month but it will definitely be
coming out in February and I've got a
lot of other course content coming out
as well what else I'm working on some
some writing projects some of which are
joint you know writing projects with
other authors some of which are just my
own stuff and you'll if you're in if you
go and patreon and you you know become a
supporter you get to see little snippets
of the stuff that I'm working on because
I let my supporters have a sneak peek
into that last thing I need to talk
about videos right what am I going to
shoot this month so I'm gonna get my
half-hour Haegele videos done you know
and maybe actually start getting a
little bit ahead of that be kind of nice
core concept videos I'm just finishing
up with heidegger's piece on Plato's
allegory of the cave then I'm going back
and doing some more Cicero videos
basically on on the work on duty and
then I'm coming back to Heidegger and
we're gonna start exploring the
introduction to being in time talking
about some of the key concepts there I'm
hoping to shoot some videos in the
existentialism series not least on this
work that I know a lot of people have
been waiting for for a very long time
cow Moos the rebel I have a tutorial
student that I'm I'm working with on the
rebel as we speak so that provides me a
great opportunity to actually shoot some
video about that so that's that's what
I'm gonna do got some personal videos
coming up this month and I'm doing at
least one interview going down to
Rockford University to interview a old
classmate who is a Santayana scholar
about Santayana
and American philosophy in general and
and about a few other things as well so
that that'll be a fun conversation I may
record some other
but I'll try to release them one once a
month and then I've got some book
reviews as I mentioned before in the
past I've got a stack of books people
have been sending me and I need to
actually start cranking those out I only
got one of them of the three I wanted to
get done last month so this month I'm
gonna start with getting this one done
the porch and the cross by Kevin vhost
which is about stoicism and Christianity
then finish up this one and review
surfing with Sartre by Aaron James which
is indeed about surfing and is indeed
about Sartre then I'm going to review
this one midlife a philosophical guide
by Kieran satya and if I can get to it
I'm going to review a book by somebody
who gave it to me at stoic on Chuck
chakrapani's unshakeable freedom also
about stoicism so I've got that going on
and I've also got a few topics that I
think are about ready for me to do a
Sadler soapbox rant about and if I get
all of that done that'll be pretty
amazing
hopefully that that will be what happens
this month but you know you never know
so we'll see so last thing I'll remind
you if you want to get in on the worlds
of speculative fiction vote or class
look at the links below really happy to
have anybody involved in that giving me
the feedback that'll that'll help about
which authors they want to see and if
the author that you really liked didn't
make it in this year well there's
there's always next year all right it's
not as if we're going to end the series
where we're gonna run out of speculative
fiction authors anytime soon we may be
doing this series four for ten years all
right so have a great month and
hopefully I'll see you at some of the
face-to-face or online events or you
know in one of my social media or in in
patreon all right
you